(soft, upbeat music)
- Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry.
(sighs)
- Welcome to America, buddy.
Oh, God.
I don't even like vodka.
- Is everything watered
down or is it just the beer?
- [Yoga Instructor]
Breathing out of Cobra.
Alright everyone, sit on your fannies.
(quirky jazz music)
- [Friend On Phone] I dunno, man.
Wear whatever you want,
shirt, jacket, pants...
- Okay.
- Dude, why aren't you wearing pants?
- (stammering) You said to...
No, I thought it was an LA thing.
(quirky music)
(hard crunching)
(pain filled exhaling)
(loud spitting)
I'm sorry.
So, do you fancy taking this
back to your place for a shag?
- Okay, sure.
Here's your shag.
- Thanks.
- Why aren't you wearing any pants?
- I am wearing pants!
- Wanna play some football?
- Do I?
(whistle blowing)
(men grunting)
- [Friend On Phone] I
dunno, why don't you wear
a shirt and vest?
That'd look cool.
- Okay.
This isn't what you meant either?
- Nope.
- Okay.
- Cathy loves wife-beaters,
I mean that's probably
why she's married to Jeff, right?
(gasping)
- (whispering) Jeff.
(sirens sounding)
- Ollie, what is going on?
- Anonymous tip into the police
to ring in a wife beater.
Job done.
- Dude, Ollie no!
What the f(beep)k?
Oh my God.
- [Ollie] Sorry.
- [Friend] I gotta get my keys.
(quirky music and police sirens)